foreign
okay the time being 10 31 and I see all
members present we'll get the meeting
underway
so this is um
the five of us are here we'll start with
um introducing ourselves I think we all
know each other but uh just uh out of
formality sake we'll introduce ourselves
and then we'll nominate uh you should
all have a agenda in front of you a
nominated chairman a clerk
um
quinoa of the dra will present the tax
expenditure report of the dra most
recent one being fiscal year 2022 2023
won't be out for another what a month or
December
okay then we'll discuss next steps plan
our next meeting date and adjourn so
um
let's start by introducing uh senator
D'Alessandro
uh Senator Lou de la Cedar I represent
District 20 that's Manchester Woods 234
10 11 and 12.
representative Fred Doucette I represent
Rockingham 25 the town of Salem
thank you
and uh dick Ames I
I represent I'm a Housewives and Means
Committee and I represent uh the towns
of Jaffrey and Dublin in Cheshire County
thank you Senator Tim Lang District 2
chair of Senate Ways and Means and
Senator delisandre forgot to add that
he's my vice chair of Senate Ways and
Means as well
thank you and I'm John janigian I am
Vice chair of the house ways and means
and I represent Salem which is
Rockingham District 25.
okay first order of business is to
nominate a chairman do I have any Mr
chair
okay do we have any other any other
nominations
all right seeing none I cast one vote
for
myself John janigian and I am now chair
of this committee
yes Senator I nominate representative
do we have any other nominations for
Clerk
you know
thank you and I cast one vote for uh
Senator Tim Lang to be clerk that was
going to be a long meeting we just sat
okay um
Ian Wong from dra call you up to present
the tax expenditure and
and if you would before you start if you
could both introduce yourselves
good morning members of the committee my
name is kin Ming Wong text policy
Council of dra
good morning my name is Lauren
O'Sullivan I'm the senior Financial
today we'll be presenting the the tax
expenditure and potential liability
report this latest report is for fiscal
year 22 as mentioned earlier the fiscal
year 23
tax expenditure and potential liability
report is due on on or before December
15th so that we have not started
preparing that report yet we'll soon be
doing that later
to start off this tax expenditure and
potential libraries report I guess just
to say that
um this report is to provide the the
committee with the
the tax expenditure or the credits that
were claimed against the business taxes
as well as any um potential foreground
taxes
amount of credits that is available on
this listed on RSA
71-c2 and those credits namely are the
community development financial
Authority credit or the new investment
tax credit the economy the economic
revitalization zone tax credit
um the research and development tax
credit the course County Job credit job
creation tax credit the education tax
credit the exemption for qualified
regenerative manufacturing companies and
that's not a credit that's essentially
as an exemption from from tax from taxes
and then the Career and Technical
Education Center Credit
this report also covers the net
operating losses the business Enterprise
tax credit the credit carryovers over uh
from over overpaid business taxes and
throughout this report uh there is going
to be mentioned or whether a credit is a
cascading credit or a not cascading
credit and that explanation is provided
on page three of the report
essentially a cascading credit as a
credit that is when taken against the
business Enterprise tax is also
deemed to be a taxes paid by the
business Enterprise tax and taken as a
credit against the business profits tax
so for starting from
from a general perspective any taxes any
business Enterprise taxes that's paid by
a business organization can be taken as
a credit against their business profits
taxes
so that's not a cascading credit that's
just how the uh the credits for business
taxes work
for a uh in in page on page three you'll
see the examples of taxpayer a where
there are no uh and no other credits so
the taxpayer a has a business Enterprise
tax liability of 2500 and the BBT
liability of 7 500. so the BET taxes
that the taxpayer pays the 2500 is used
against the BPT and you see that 7 500
less 2500.
and so the total taxes that's being paid
by this taxpayer a is five thousand
dollars so that is the um the general
starting point of of tax credits
and then in taxpayer B situation where
the taxpayer gets a credit
and but that of 2 500 but that's not a
cascading credit so that is applied
against bet so you see here that bet
2500 original liability less than 2500
you have zero bet taxes and then for BPT
it's still 7 500 because there's no bet
taxes paid so in this situation the
taxpayer B uh owes seventy five hundred
dollars
an in taxpayer scenario where there is a
cascading credit so that twenty five
hundred dollars
first applied against the bet
and then cuts down the BET to zero
however that twenty five hundred dollars
can then also still be used against the
BPT
and so 75 that's 2500 is 5 000 and
therefore the total tax to buy taxpayers
is five thousand so that essentially
lays out the uh the the concept of a
cascading credit and that applies to
some of the credits on this report are
cascading credits and some are not so
this just gives out the the base
um
so moving on to page four it just lists
out uh what I mentioned earlier uh what
are the the credits that will be
mentioned on on this report
and page five provides a a brief
overview of the workings of the credits
here you'll see uh listing each of the
credits
the statutes
that is um
that applies to these credits and then
the the taxes
that is applicable to these credits and
then the cap if is there is a cap on the
credits and and so on and so forth so
this is a very good um
reference point when you're reviewing
each each of the credits you can refer
back to this page and look back as to
the the general overview of each of
can I just ask a question
um the um so the current year cap on
program that's total of all so if we
look at the first one cdfa new
investment the five million that's for
all
taxpayers combined that's the that's
correct so so the cdfa I believe cdfa is
um it's administered by the community
development financial Authority and so
they will issue a a credit out to those
um contributions that they received for
that particular year up to five million
representative Ames has a question
with regard to cascading credits
um
I'm wondering if you
see any rationale for
the diff the difference of the picking
outs what do we have we got one two
three
of these uh tax expenditure programs
uh to uh have the cascading credit and
another four
that do not have it is there can you
just discern anything other than maybe
it just happened uh that way
um I I believe this is all uh it's
potentially a policy decision made by
legislature when they enacted these
credits
um so that I can't say much further than
then moving on to page six uh and this
is also another page with summary
information
uh it lists out the amount of credits
that's used on each of the credits um
that's then provided in more detail in
and I'll move on to page so uh so that's
the amount used as of the well as of
2022 so if I look at research and
development tax credit
5.308 million that's only that much was
used out of 7 million uh yes that's the
amount of credit that uh that was
claimed on the returns that was that
were submitted in fiscalia 22. so the
these yes that's a good point uh
representative so these credits that's
utilized here are captured for the
returns that submitted in fiscal year
22.
um returns that submitted in fiscal year
22 could be
um you know could be late returns could
be returned as submitted on time so it
potentially could be 20 tax year 21
returns could be older returns but
whatever returns that we received by the
dra during the fiscal year 22 period
thank you yep
okay
so they do not correspond to the program
year caps so that's where you will see
that timing difference
so I guess that's my question so I'm
looking at and using the r d tax credit
as a great example right we authorize up
to seven million dollars in tax credits
but we only got applied five million 5.3
million in tax credits were applied for
does that mean that all uh assuming the
uh the applying business
um asks for the maximum 50 I think it's
fifty thousand dollars in the maximum
right
um they because we're not at the cap
they would receive the full fifty
thousand dollar credit
so what happens is that uh as Lauren
mentioned is that there is a timing
difference but when the
um when the credit is applied for by the
business organizations as and when the
the business organizations file their
return and claim the credit so
um the the Caps here as you mentioned is
the the credits that's awarded
whereas the amounts on page six is the
credits that's claimed on the return so
that with that timing difference you
could potentially see oh why some why
are some of these credits maybe the
amounts are higher than what the cap is
that's because well the taxpayers are
holding on to the credits some of the
credits can be carried over too when
they're not using in the year that they
claim it in in the following year and
they claim the credit so all that well
that accumulates and they could
potentially raise the the amount of
credit that's claimed higher than the
cap that's provided so again if they if
they didn't have a tax liability they
can hold that credit for a following
year when they may have a tax liability
and you know how long that carry forward
is uh depending on the the program yeah
so then it in this case it's 5.3 million
but there are scenarios where people
held on to them you could go over 7
million
yes and and also I'd like to add too
that's the cap
possible
with enough applications and some of
these the Caps aren't met and the other
ones we do meet the cap every year so
you also might see that too you may only
have two million on a five million
dollar cap that's actually awarded
follow-up so again so again my
understanding if I remember right from a
couple hearings is that these credits
though are prorated if we exceed the cap
right is that yes for the r d credit yes
that's how that means that at least for
this reporting cycle that the amount of
credit used
um it didn't exceed the cap and
therefore they got they were it was in
prorated
so um for r d credits that there is
actually
um let me just double check here
there are a mixture of
um
applications that exceeded the the fifty
thousand dollars and there are
applications that's below the fifty
thousand dollars and that combination
um
so but then the maximum amount of
credits that can be awarded is kept at
the seven million dollars
um but then once again this 5.3 million
is when they claim it versus when
what's awarded right
again I'm just looking at the history of
that specific credit right it's 5
million 5.3 5.6
5.3553 right we never got near the cap
of seven and in theory assuming the the
business
asked for the maximum they would have
got the maximum because there was no cap
on that we didn't hit the cap or
um or if it was lower if they only
accounted for forty thousand dollars in
the credit they only got a forty
thousand dollar credit because that's
what they applied for uh in total the
amount of um credits that's requested
for r d did exceed the 7 million and
now I'm confused because why would they
be prorated yeah I'm trying to
understand we have the expenditures on
page nine of the r d tax credit not one
of them goes over seven million dollars
so why would we prorate it sorry the
appropriation is for the 50 million if
you exceed to 50 million oh okay so
you're saying that they met they reached
the cap and therefore they might have
been eligible for a hundred thousand
dollars in r d credit but because we
have a program cap of 50 they only
receive 50. so that's the proration but
not because the cap of the actual
it was the cap of the individual
applicant was exceeded
the
requested value
I would say yes yeah at this I think so
too but I just want to make sure I'm
clear
because I'm assuming I'll have similar
so
wait so I understand individual
application may be prorated because
they're asking for more than they're
entitled to uh by law so therefore they
ask for 65 because that's what they paid
out for r d and that they're only
because of the cap is 50 we've prorated
it down to 50 and given them the max but
what we didn't do is I was entitled to
50 but I exceeded the cap of the entire
program so therefore I'm only getting
45. right so so we didn't do that we
only did it on the individual basis
based on the maximum per user cap thank
you
sorry I didn't mean to go off on them no
let's
go okay okay so
um we'll go on to the uh purse credit
which is the community development
financial Authority uh all the new
investment tax credit
so this credit is administered by the
cdfa
um and it's
essentially uh we we can't talk too much
about the administration of of the the
program because that's administered by
the cdfa
um and what we do know is that it is to
the this tax this credit it's a
cascading credit
and it may be used against the BET
liability and then used against the BPT
liability
so the credit that's used um this amount
reported and used
in fiscal year 22 were 20 211 taxpayers
and then the amount of credits that were
claimed in fiscal year 22 was 4.2
million dollars
and you can see from a trend from fiscal
year 2018 uh right to physically 22
um there was a slight decline from
fiscal year 2018 to 19 and then uh it
went back up to 20 50 to 20.
oh sorry it went back down fiscally 19
to 50 20 664 down to 144 but it went
back up in 21 because we get 21. and
continue to increase in fiscal year 22.
and this is an example of the timing
between the awarding of the credit and
when it's claimed so what you see here
the fiscal year 22 number exceeds the
3.75 million but when we looked at how
it was awarded they were awarded
appropriately at that cap for those
years that they were eligible but it's
just the timing of when those returns
okay so the in any one year you may
exceed the cap in terms of the the
absolute number but each year the amount
yes and it's this cdfa that Awards the
credit
amount yep I'm sorry say that again it's
the cdfa that Awards the credit okay and
then then the taxpayer claims it on the
return and then we capture that
information okay Senator Lang so again I
just wanna sorry again I just want to be
clarifying this is that this has a 75
um the the credit is 75 of the uh actual
credit I don't know how else to say that
but it's kind of a weird statement but
we have five million authorized up too
but they only get 75 percent of that
which is 3.75 million that could be
awarded in credit so people can donate
up to five million dollars to the
program but they're only going to get
3.5 3. whatever the numbers
um 75 million in possible credits but
and you can also see that uh from uh
this uh this credit that there's a
carryover provision for this credit so
before this there were questions about
you know which one is a has a credit
carryover and this one has a credit card
over up to five years
right
all right
any other questions on
on this one
saying none I guess we can go to the
right the the next credit is the
economic revitalization zone tax credit
or the erz tax credit
um this credit uh currently is set to
repeal effective January of 2028
and this credit is also not administered
by the dra it's administered by the
business economic business and economic
affairs
um and it is to encourage the payroll
and capital expenditure
um of of the companies in the um in
those economic most designated economic
uh so the this erz tax credit shall be
applied against the business profits tax
first and any unused portion will be
um and then any further unused portion
of this credit can be carried over for
five years
this is a cascading credit
and in fiscal year 22 there were 41
taxpayers that received this that apply
and claim this credit for the total
now it's just expiring in 2028 uh
because it was tied to the um
uh the jobs Act of uh uh I believe I
don't believe so
um I'm not sure but it was uh it was
something in the
in the uh laws of 2020 in initially
these this erz credit has an earlier
expiration but legislature has seen fit
to actually extend the
um the the repeal date year over year
and now it's set to expire Janu 1 2028
all right moving on to uh the r d credit
so this one is administered by the dra
um
this some history on this it was
initially due to repeal in on July 1st
of 2015 but then that repeal date was
repealed um so it's not not going to be
there's no sunset on this r d credit and
uh and um on the first one there was no
end date either it's a cdfa oh yeah no
okay
um and so the this credit is uh
calculated on the uh the wages the
qualifying Wages that's made by paid by
the the taxpayers and these wages are
um and as discussed earlier the each
taxpayer shall not exceed the fifty
thousand dollar limit on the claim on
the the ward of the r d credit
um and then the cap is seven million
dollars for the amount of um r d credit
that is awarded each year
for fiscal year 22 there were 235
taxpayers that actually claimed this
credit
and out of that it amounts to 5.3
million dollars of um
thank you any questions on r d i i just
one quick one clarifying again I just
want to make sure I'm clear so when
we're looking at the fiscal year 2022
expenditure of 513 million
that's when the credit was applied to
their tax liability so it may have been
incurred in a prior year but it wasn't
actually used and these numbers are
representing when that credit is used
moving on page 10 that is the coast
County job creation credit uh then this
credit is administered by the business
and economic affairs
um and so this credit is targeted to
cause County
um it's to for foster the creation of
additional high quality jobs
and the definition of high quality jobs
uh is Wages that is greater than 150 of
the current state minimum wage
um
this credit shall first be applied
against the BET taxes and any remainder
should be applied against the BPT
any unused credits can be carriable for
five years and this is another one of
the examples of a cascading credit
in fiscal year 22 there were 24
taxpayers that that claimed this credit
and for and then amounted to ninety six
any three uh that's it looks like a
significant drop do we have any idea of
what caused that
uh we don't have a lot of details on
that because this is administered by the
business and economic Affairs they
issued the award of the credits
um that agency potentially could see
maybe uh could maybe provide information
as maybe how many
um credits were awarded each fiscal year
but all we can say is that the amount of
taxpayers that claim the credit has has
decreased yeah
okay
any other questions yeah
the next credit is the education tax
credit and this credit is a message by
um and this credit is based on the
amount of the donations that's made to
approve scholarship organizations
the tax credit is against the BPT bet
and interest in dividends tax up to 85
percent value of the donations made
and of course with the uh with the
repeal of the IND tax uh
the early repeal of the IND tax in Texas
24 onwards so
um you will see that the application of
the credits will
will not impact the uh I mean probably
more if the individuals
who worked claiming this credit will not
be able to claim his credit anymore
um and if there were business
organizations that were claiming IND
taxes they will not be claiming the
credit against their IND taxes
potentially then moving it to the bptm
um
this credit program is credit award is
kept at 5.1 million dollars
this credit
issue maybe cared for it for five years
um and then the amount of the number of
taxpayers that claim this Credit in
fiscal 22 was 120
for a total amount of 1.5 million
dollars
and you see that trend of increasing
from fiscal year 18 through fiscal year
um
in terms of the the number of taxpayers
claimings great
it's interesting we're nowhere near the
cap but with the number of taxpayers
increasing
maybe uh it'll get there at some point
representative Ames yeah
um is looking at the report files last
year I guess
2022 by Patrick abrami for this
committee
um
said about this tax credit that it he
noted that the tax credits amounted to
1.909 million which is the number we
have here for fiscal year 21.
and um
that there would be more growth than
there has been so I know I you really
aren't on top of the details of what's
happening with these education tax
credits I imagine because the Department
of Education managed process but I may
be wrong about that
and I just curious about what is
happening the actual use
well the amount charged
was 1.9 last year and 1.545 this year
um
so what's happening this is the question
once again this could be oh so
um
a question of when the credits were
awarded versus when the credits were
claimed under return
um
yes we do see a drop from 1.9 to a 1.5
um and I think that is
the the amount of credits that were
awarded could potentially have
been higher than that but then the
amount that's claimed in fiscal 22 is
showing that 1.5 million dollars
well you know what you know that what
I'm I mean this is just my guess but if
I look at fiscal year 19 to fiscal year
20 you went from 74 to 110 a huge
increase and my guess is not all those
were taken right away they got the
credits they didn't use them right away
and then it gets reflected in that huge
number in 21 of 1.9 million and then you
see the numbers moderating to a huge
degree now it's just six more and then
four more and thus the drop kind of
makes sense because now a lot of those
pent-up credits have been used
just a guess based on looking at these
numbers
I think it would be if we can manage it
at some point it would be uh worth
having it in the
the two funds that actually
administered and make the
an issue
the awards to uh for scholarships
because last year when we had
a ground floor
days that the scholarship fund indicated
that 698 scholarships in 2010 to 21 was
granted averaging
2832 first dollars so if the obvious
question is what what's what's happened
since then yeah I mean it's not a bad
idea and one of the things we'll discuss
after this
is in in Patrick abrami's report he
mentioned that they they analyzed three
of the seven funds and this that was one
of them so there's four that weren't
looked at so we may have to look at how
much time do we have and maybe we should
look at those four instead of looking at
this again although I I do find Meriden
in your um comment there
Senator Lang so again I just don't want
to make sure we don't confuse the 1.5
million is not amount not the amount
that was awarded in scholarships right
that is strictly the amount of credits
that were applied to an individual's
returns so those things are not it's
equal right um so there may be in the
fund more money than was you know that
and we can talk to you know Kate Baker
and he had Department of Education on
what that on the purpose of the usage of
that fund but it looked like Pat did
that last year
um but I just want to make sure
everyone's clear 1.5 is it the amount
that that was issued in scholarships it
was strictly the amount of tax credit
issued to businesses or individuals that
were applying either IND tax BBT tax or
bet tax and donated to that organization
and therefore was ineligible for an 85
return on a tax credit so and that's
what that represents is the 85 percent
of the tax credit that was issued and
also I would like to add you had
mentioned the 698 credit scholarships
awarded at the average twenty eight
hundred dollars so that was in 2021 and
2122 I have that in front of me it was
1171 scholarships were awarded so nearly
double and that was at two point uh 2
943 was the average scholar Fellowship
so the um the average allowable
scholarship goes up every year and
that's based on an inflation adjustment
adjustment so then for 22.23 it's now
2995 for the average and
1443 scholarships were awarded
so that is growing there are more
scholarships being awarded
I'm sorry what was the last year or I
guess sure so the scholarships awarded
this is 22.23
and that is 1443.
and the average allowable scholarship is
2995. the one before that you said
Eleven Hundred and seventy one
scholarships and what was the average
award two thousand nine hundred forty
three
and the the next um
tax expenditure is the exemption for
qualified regenerative manufacturing
companies
uh this is administered by the dra once
again this is not a credit essentially
it is an exemption uh from uh tax from
business profits and business Enterprise
tax these uh entities that qualify as a
qualified regenerative manufacturing
company they submitted an application to
the dra saying that they are these kinds
of companies and then there are treat it
as not business organizations and they
would need to annually file
informational
documents to us to maintain that status
because the number of
um
qualifying companies is less than the
disclosure threshold we're not able to
and this is uh this this exemption
expires for taxable peers beginning
maybe I missed the beginning of your
description why you don't have a chart
on this one like you did with the other
ones because the amount of
qrmc qualified regenerative
manufacturing companies is less than the
threshold disclosure that disclosures
threshold that we're allowed to provide
so we cannot provide the uh we're we're
bound to not provide the the any
statistical information on this what is
that disclosure threshold uh for
Statewide is 10 taxpayers oh 10 10
records
10 records
less than 10 businesses have applied for
this tax credit so therefore we can't
disclose could be easy to determine
which end might be that's correct
position oh I see okay less than 10 have
claimed claimed it or filed something
and that's the informational filing
okay
yeah my apologies Mr chairs we spoke
before I have a previous
no problem thanks for thanks for coming
by
this was my first term in the house this
bill this bill was passed and so again
the reasoning for this tax credit the
background behind this tax credit was we
basically wanted to create the Silicon
Valley of the East
um for regenerative medicine was the
idea right
um and we've got like less than 10
businesses but some businesses coming in
and doing it we also recognize the fact
that by its nature startups aren't
profitable you know most startups are
not profitable so the impact is going to
be minimal to begin with because they
wouldn't be paying BBT and they would be
able to be paying bet potentially but
again we wanted to encourage them to
come in so we're basically giving them a
waiver on BET in order to create a a
core Focus for New Hampshire I think
it's been semi-effective we've had some
good progress come out of that Army AR
armi the advanced regenerative medicine
initiative
um in New Hampshire so uh just for a
little background for members yeah thank
you so and this also implies that no
credits have been taken at this point
it's not a credit it's an exemption from
business taxes it's an exemption okay
and is there a limit on
those exemptions there's there's no
limit no
okay 10-year a 10-year pass yeah
okay
I mean I guess what I'm struggling with
I don't have a full understanding of it
is how do we know what the impact is
to State revenues
or we don't I
Senator I was a co-sponsor of the bill
that that created this exemption and I
think it's it's an unknown at this point
in time
the uh
the company that this was uh
developed for has ex has expanded it it
Manchester it has grown the rest of the
number of employees
Etc I don't know what that is but there
there has been growth in that area in
another company in the regenerative
business has relocated the Baychester
also so I know I know of two companies
that would qualify for this at this at
this point point type both located in in
Manchester but
I don't think we have any idea of of
really what's what's happening in terms
of activity there and financial activity
the only thing we do know is that uh DOD
has given two grants
for uh for this entity to get going one
was from about 80 billion in the second
was for another 20 million so there's
100 million of investment or the part of
DOD in this in this operation okay
so the um it sounds like the good news
is there's some activity happening and
the hope would be that eventually these
companies grow to the point where they
are paying business profits and vet well
again as of December 31st 2027 I'll be
paying bet at that point again this was
basically a startup provisional allow
businesses to get a foothold and get
anchored in understanding that in 10
years that critical the exemption goes
the next credit is the Career and
Technical Education Center Credit on
this system ID Department of Education
uh so the purpose is to encourage
charitable donations to Regional Career
and Technical education centers
um the maximum amount of credits issued
to all donors will is kept at fifty five
hundred thousand dollars and this
program is scheduled to be repealed
after fiscal year 2026. once again this
was another example of uh where the
information the number of Records is
um
it's below the
the reporting thresh the disclosure
threshold then we can provide any
information on
it is a it is not a cascading credit
though
representative Ames we should at least
note that this is a program that's
scheduled to be repealed after fiscal
okay
foreign
so this part of the report is additional
information
um and this is on the first item here is
net operating losses and this is only
applicable to the reduction in business
profits taxes there have been a few
developments in the area of net
operating losses uh recently in the
legislature one being that the net
operating losses will only be apportion
once as opposed to previously it was
twice a portion in the year that the
losses would incurred and then the year
the losses was was applied so that has
changed currently the um and then also
the calculation of net operating loss is
now tied to the uh internal Internal
Revenue code of 2018
previously it was tied to the Internal
Revenue code of 96.
um and this the the carryovers oh sorry
the nols that's generated a new actually
has a cap on the the nols it caps it at
10 million dollars per entity
I and it's only available for any carry
forwards of unused nols to up to 10
years
um in fiscal year 22 there were 6995
business organizations that were that
claimed the nol deduction
um in total nols use after apportionment
is 470 million dollars
and then the average annual use so we
take the 470 million divide by 6995
taxpayers of business organizations come
up with an average NL per uh business
organization of 67 000 to 37.
and the total tax decrease due to nol is
and you see year over year in terms of
the trend there is an increase in the
um I guess I have a general question if
you know the answer to this I mean this
is so now this is report of additional
information
does is this committee is reviewing the
tax expenditure is this considered
one of those yes okay so so there's more
than seven then this there's
every state
or maybe more this champion
so one thing I will find interesting is
that we were talking earlier about like
even on the Community Development
Finance Authority right they were there
the actual taking of the credit was
pretty low up until we hit 22. and then
we saw a big taking you know an increase
over a million 1.2 million dollars an
increase in cdfa from three million
dollars by 4.2 million dollars where
businesses are actually or individuals
are taking that credit
um and we're seeing the same thing here
I think in this so that we see 22 as an
outlier where a significant number of
businesses are taking credits that are
hanging at that are that are available
um so just as a comment and more than
anything else is that we're seeing more
businesses use up those tax credits
which for this year reduces the amount
of Revenue but it also reduces the
liability so we're not having those
credits hang out there either so it's a
it's a protocon in there that the
liability of the state's reduced because
we don't have we don't have those
okay
moving on to the next page is Page 15
there's a business Enterprise tags
um and so uh this business Enterprise
any taxes any business Enterprise tax is
paid will be considered as a credit can
be taken as a credit against business
profits tax so
um
and they're in fiscal year 22 there were
38 000 returns
um that file had had a bad liability and
total let that Library report it was
2019 million dollars
um in the BET used against BPT is 183
so again on a this is a one-to-one ratio
so if I have a thousand dollars in BPT
yes but I paid 100 in in bet I can take
that hundred dollars take it off the BPT
liability exactly and I only have a 900
in total you'll still be
um
you'll still be that one thousand
dollars because it offsets
um and also note that not all taxpayers
uh will have both bet and bet you know
some textures might have a higher bet
than BBT uh essentially maybe those will
be taxpayers with more payroll heavy
oriented businesses
um like those
I guess
consultancy services with heavy payroll
yeah
so again you actually struck me with a
question though a person pays more BBT
than they oh they don't get a credit
they get a credit to follow that forward
so again if say I paid a thousand
dollars in B E.T but I only have 100
liability I just get the net zero out my
zero out my PPT I don't get it 900 bucks
back from the state no that's not a
but it can be carried forward 10 years
yes so that 900 difference can be
carried forward to another year and used
entities are exempt from the bet the
basic statute
who doesn't pay the bet
oh the there's a threshold amount of I
believe right now is 203
000 or something like that for uh enter
business Enterprise Value
so if the uh the business organization's
Enterprise Value is less than that then
they won't need to be submitting a bad
return
other than that um if they have any
business organization or business
Enterprise that has more than that
threshold will be required to um to
submit a bad return unless they qualify
as a qrmc
then they will be Exempted I believe the
statute certain entities are exempt from
the bet
and I believe even
um
I believe even the uh
5013c organizations probably I believe
they are also they're not exempt I
believe they do have to
um file a bad return if they meet the
threshold
but I need to double check them just
just remember the implementation of the
statute okay thank you thank you thank
you
I'm sorry so again I think you're so
your question was Senator was our 50c3
type organizations exempt from BET and
the answer is we're not sure right now
yeah I believe they are not exempt
um I believe so but I just need to
okay looking at the statute
I think anyway I'll re-look at it just
to make sure
all right obviously if we can get yeah
and moving on to page 16 this is the uh
credit carryovers of from overpaid
business taxes this is the uh the the
big issue with the ccos
um and once again the the latest
development in in this uh credit carrier
over issue is that for taxable peers and
the owner will be after December 3122
their credits that's allowed to be
carried over is up to 500 percent of the
total tax liability uh for the taxable
period and then the remainders shall be
refunded and that cap will be
reduced in to 250 percent of the taxable
periods ending on or after December 31
2025 and then up to 100 only uh for
taxable peers and the owner after
December 31 2027.
foreign
so you see here in the um
well fiscally 22 and you can see that
the trend from specifically 21 to fiscal
22 the the number of uh credit carriers
has dropped from 20 000 to 17 000 uh but
then you'll see the fiscal year 21
through 22 the amount of uh credit card
over is actually increased from 297 to
um so I guess then the question is uh
are we seeing the are we not seeing the
impact of this 500 cap
um but bear in mind this is information
for fiscal year 22. so for fiscal year
22 mainly uh for calendar year filers
this likely would be for um texture 2020
calendar year filers because
um tax year 2020 the returns are due
April 15 of 21 and most of the filers
actually file
on extension and then they returns it up
will see the returns in November of 21
and that falls into fiscal year 22. so
for tax year 22 this cap has not does
not apply to those taxpayers yet because
it only applies to the uh for taxable
appears ending on or after December 31
22 to 500 so likely you'll see uh as
Laura mentioned earlier during the
conversation is that we are starting to
see some impact on this 500 cap and in
the current
um current period yes so we started so
we started seeing
um very small impacts on the small and
medium-sized businesses because they hit
that 500 very quickly on their liability
and we started seeing that a little bit
in April and and a little bit every
month and this is the first month where
it's starting to ramp up a little bit
where we see the number of refunds are
due to hitting that
um 500 percent cap but we're still
probably not going to see it on the very
large organizations and the large fiscal
filers either later this year or even
next year or when we get to the 250.
okay
so I mean extraordinarily High to hit
500 when you're very large right so
taxpayers themselves may or may not know
about this
law but you the dra is saying okay
you've hit 500 and you're sending money
back correct our system is set up to
identify those and and then to issue
those refunds and also one thing we have
noticed is that some taxpayers are
electing to just keep a hundred percent
of their liability on the books and not
take the full 500 that they still could
have for even next tax year because the
250 doesn't begin until tax year 25.
but they are opting for the 100 now
Senator Lang
so do we have a list of liability like
what is our outstanding liability for
for these credit carrier carryovers
what's the gross number we're looking at
hanging out there and how many how many
taxpayers hit the 500 threshold or will
hit the Five Mile threshold
and what what is the amount we expect to
be refunded
we don't have that ready quite yet we
know
um what is outstanding I don't have that
information in front of me right now
that what that is part of the fiscal
year closing process so we did provide
that to admin Services I just do not
have the number and the count in front
of me and
um we're only really evaluating refunds
that are 10 000 or greater or you
requested a credit in tax year 22.
so we haven't evaluated every single
refund that went out the door
well Mr chair I guess I'd ask for that
because hey that's going to impact
revenues and I'd kind of like to have an
idea what that looks like if we know
that
um that uh and you know the 22 numbers
the 500 percent how much anybody who's
above 500 how much money are refunding
back because that's money that's not
going basically coming out of the
general fund regardless of Revenue is
coming in so I'd like to see what that
net difference is looking like
and then the same if we can what we
project out for 25 that reduction of 250
here's our estimated liability and we'll
be writing checks for this much money in
on January 1. you know to to taxpayers
and what that number looks like so we
have an estimate of what that those
revenue or those yeah those spending
those expenditures are going to look
like
that would be good that would be good
again
yes representative Ames
just trying to make sure I've got this
um
so before this change
taxpayer
um
could choose either to leave it with the
department or not and I was left with
with the state
it would be
part of the revenue reported by the
agency is that right
um
what used to be
revenue and hang in there until maybe
there was a subsequent
change of mind by the taxpayer
um
uh what's changed is that now there's a
mandatory
um
Credit in effect uh return of money to
the taxpayer
which means that
well we counted as Revenue before under
our different different system will no
longer be Revenue
in this new system do I have this more
or less right
um so I mean it's essentially what
happens is with with the the 500
limitation anything in excess of the 500
will be refunded to the taxpayer so that
refund goes against the revenue reducing
the revenue number in the future here
though but the but the revenue came in
in the previous year so we're we
accounted for it there but we're taking
it off now it has a refund right right
that's why it's important to understand
what that number looks like sure
remember budgeting purposes
we are proactively
um sending out letters to taxpayers that
have credit and asking them to make a
decision if they want instead of just
assuming leave the credit on account we
ask please respond back if you want to
leave a credit on account or then a
refund will be issued if there is no
response
right so that's also another way to
mitigate this liability that's on the
book you're doing that for all all
credits not just over 500 but it work
right it's like you currently have X
number of dollars on account with us
yeah you want to use them or you want to
okay sounds good
next
yeah so and the last item here on page
17 that is the insurance premium taxes
um and this is a credit against the
business profits tax so the uh insurance
companies that pays his insurance
premium taxes the the premiums that they
pay can be used to offset against the
business profits taxes
um
and here the
total credits used against BPT for in
fiscal year 22 came up to about 44
million dollars in the total number of
taxpayers utilizing this credit was uh
273 taxpayers
so that that 44 million dollars that the
state took that in as taxes on insurance
companies and then they deducted it from
their BPT yep okay
so it's one or the other I mean right
yeah
makes sense
did you have a question
no I no I just want to make sure that
the 273 doesn't represent represents
insurance companies not you know in some
form that's paying this premium this
insurance premium tax and then we're
just saying that you can take that off
your off your business profits tax right
that those are the uh insurance
companies that claimed the ipt against
the BPT
all right the other
do you have anything else or is that
pretty much it all right that's that's
pretty much it so we'll be starting to
prepare the fiscal year 23 report uh
later in the year
um and um we I think so this this report
this fiscal year 22 report was uh was
issued on December 22 so the fiscal year
23 report likely will be around the same
time frame in terms of when it will be
issued and for the purposes of this
committee we have to have a report uh
done by November 1st so we won't be able
to include any of that of course but um
just like the previous committee to us
um looked at 2021 and wrote a report in
. I'm sorry Mr chair I think my bank
yeah the summary so there were there
were a couple basic things were asking
for you to come back with information
one was the question around who pays bet
and understanding better what that looks
like and who's exempt from the BET and
then the other items were about the
liability on the credit carryovers what
that looks like you know how it's going
to be hit against future revenues
okay next on our agenda is discussing
I'm gonna definitely need a little help
here figuring this out if I look at
representative abrami's report from last
year
they they did and actually Senator were
you on uh last year okay so just uh
representative Ames I believe was here
last year so yeah um so it looks like
representative Ames last year the
committee addressed
uh three of the seven
um
tax expenditures but did not it looks
like
um
do not move forward with four of them
the education tax credit
The revitalization Zone tax credit the
koas County job creation tax credit
and the Community Development Finance
Authority
so it I mean it probably makes sense for
I mean the fact that
well I guess I I have just a general
question that you may be able to answer
representative Ames is that our our
report is supposed to be in by November
1st
um
is that the end of this committee at
that point I had the same question I
didn't look at the statute uh is it here
I mean I'd be okay if it was plenty of
other things
going on
yeah what happened last year after you
after that report that ran along and we
ran out of members uh Senator resigned
and
he was gone and uh just uh abrahamian me
but then but then that was he was he
dropped out before the November 1st so
then November 1st report came out and
then did you guys do anything after
November 1st oh no okay we were done
um
so it says
it's funny The Joint Committee on tax
suspended reviews hereby has established
a review all qualifying taxes Spenders
on a rotating basis every five years
um and recommended continuous Amendment
a repeal of relevant Provisions right
that's our charge right
um
first being recall within 90-day
because every November 1st thereafter
The Joint Committee shall plan for any
tax expenditures or subsequently enacted
or amended and Report required so I'm
guessing it's an ongoing yeah that's the
way we do that's where we treated that
last time so we did a
I guess we call it an internal report of
some sort for
what is now this November right and then
we did a fuller report a year later so
the this report that we're talking about
right now was just to cover ourselves
basically and say we've had a meeting
and discuss lessons so and uh
and a few more things I'm sure we can
find it and um and then we carried on so
we weren't done okay yeah so
um
are presumably our our committee would
then produce another report for 2024 or
November 1st and then the committee
would be done because now it's a new
biennium right that's what happens okay
so so when that new report comes I mean
it seems like
there'll be no rush to I mean after
November 1st we probably don't have to
meet again for
a while
um yeah whatever that means but we'll
figure it out based on
I think a lot of us are new so we we
don't know how much work is it going to
take and depending on what we see and
what we feel like we still need to do we
can figure what we did was
um
I believe the report
the November this year report was short
and reported that we met around
um had a presentation from dra right
um
and might identify maybe we should agree
on this a plan to
proceed to develop information on the
before
um
tax expenditure programs that are
mentioned in a brownies report as not
having been addressed yet right
um and uh that would be our plan then
then we would get together
as soon as we can
um
right given all the other things that
are going to be happening to us and
try to get it done and I know last time
around we just ran out of
time and Personnel because we lost some
of the Guida and it was a three-person
community to start with so we were in
trouble and uh we
decided not to go much further and
basically report it out so the
requirement for November 1st is every
November 1st thereafter The Joint
Committee shall file a report with
recommendations for proposed legislation
including identification and review
uh plan for any tax expenditures that
was subsequently enacted or amended
so I guess considering we did the three
last year
I guess my recommendation was take the
four that weren't done last year yeah
and then I understand we're gonna do the
three next year yeah 24. right so let's
keep that cycling of four this year
three next year four Vision that makes
sense that makes sense uh the four
includes the education tax credit which
we
we've received information on but we
didn't
we didn't engage in the discussion and
Analysis that we needed to do as a
committee so it was incomplete that's
why it's on the list so who came and
talked here though the uh Kate Baker
the director of
the scholarship program organization
came and talked with talked to us I
guess I can I could reach out to um dra
on on those four and find out who yeah I
think is that yeah it was the uh in the
other cases the
uh what's it called the business and
development uh
the the agency that administers the
uh I think the revitalization the cdfa
oh yeah tax credit there are different
different amenities
um yeah
so I don't have that on top of it all
right so
um and then what you know to my question
earlier
the um you know you have the seven and
then then it looks like there's four
other
liabilities and it doesn't seem like
that's not mentioned in abrami's report
have the data oh okay
yeah
okay
yeah and I don't I don't know where I
got mine I when I first was the first
listed House member and I had no idea
what this committee even did I asked for
some information and I and I got
so again the two items that are required
on the report is potential liabilities
against State revenues specifically
lists out some tax credits
um and then credit carry uh and credit
carryovers so those are kind of the two
that's listed on here we have to
identify so it's not addressing nol or
business Enterprise well I don't know I
have to go look at just get statute
numbers oh I don't know what all those
strategy numbers are so we'd have to go
through and look up what each one of
those statues represents okay um it's
like other credits allowed on RSA 77
77-a 77-e 77-g78 78-a 78-b 82
82-83-e
84-84-c and RSA 400-a against the
business profit Stacks so I don't know
what all those credit programs and carry
forward programs are by those rsas we
probably need to identify those and make
um yeah
yeah so that report
I have
so that report doesn't even address any
of those yeah that's what I'm saying I
don't I don't so I think it was because
they ran short they ran out of time and
they gave what they had they gave and
the rest be damned so we and and we may
not be able to address all that given
our tight time frame now well we have
two years right so I think that we can
specify you just say that these these
Provisions will be carrying forward to
2024 November first report yeah I just
meant by this November 1st We're Not
Gonna no no no no no so and I think you
know you just use common sense and right
do what you can do and don't worry about
it so let's maybe we start with Senator
there was a huge concern of norms
that as we as we what he worried about
was this
Cloud hanging over us that might
cause damage and that the cloud was that
there were businesses out there who had
on deposit with the state a huge amount
of money and they might someday
uh look at the crystal ball and say
whoops it's time for us to take all that
money back well my my concern is that in
talking to him in that conversation was
again if now we're being forced to issue
refunds what's that look like and maybe
we need to consider consider legislation
as spread that out a little longer
rather than a two-year cycle getting
down from 500 to 100 yeah so maybe
that's possible legislation we want to
consider to not have as a drastic of an
impact some of that on my back but some
of that may be answered when he comes
back when we get the numbers some
additional information
is you know era has addressed the
they just send it back yeah
what talk about it cascading effect
what's what effect is that going to have
or that's
door
right yeah that's why Senator Lang is
saying maybe we stretched that out
because it who knows yeah yeah it's 100
a year we reduce it by over the next
five years rather than a 500 to zero 500
to 100 over two years it's it's that's
fast yeah
okay um so then
for the next meeting maybe we try to get
those for
um I'll have to find out who the experts
are in those four areas and we'll have
presentations on on those four
you probably can't do them all at once
too much too much
um
each one has has a constituent suit
which one so they were idiot day right
the economic revitalization tax credit
yeah r d was that already in his report
that's already done yeah so that costs
County jobs County the education tax
credit was done but we'll need to review
it again next year okay yeah the CT was
done wasn't it well wait a minute he
listed it as not being done well he
listed
[Music]
there is a conclusions of required hacks
so they did do an assessment of it but
they just didn't you know they said
needs that needs a deeper dive as well
so again we're going to do a deeper dive
we're just going to put it off to the
next okay all right so so what you're
proposing is um
cdfa
cdfa economic revitalization koas County
it's all on the front page well again
the insurance premium tax credit right
those are the four that he really didn't
do it aren't talked about really in this
report at all oh I see right those are
the four tax credits listed by dra as an
expenditure
um that we have to look at plus right we
have this other these other liability
under additional item the nol Enterprise
tax credit and
um credit carry forward which I think we
should do the credit carry forward this
year
right an analysis we should
until we get five items for this report
and they are again cdfa economic koas
County insurance tax premium and the
and we should maybe focus on those on
the next coming meetings
um insurance tax premium so that wasn't
one of the
four that he didn't get done though
right but it's these are listed again
I'm using dras acknowledge so again if
you go to page five they list an
overview of tax expenditures and amounts
right you know the insurance one is uh
not very exciting I suppose yeah I'm
sure it's going to be a really quick but
again we should at least have it someone
come in and talk to us about it make
sure we're okay and yeah yeah one one
paragraph and we're done
but at least we reviewed it and had a
conversation with somebody
all right so cdfa
Economic Development
call us
Cross County insurance tax credit
premium credit and then a credit card
repo which is going to be the big one I
think
okay
well that's we're talking hundreds about
hundreds of millions of dollars versus
these
you know right okay so credit carry
forward is dra yeah
insurances insurance
um the way insurance department and dra
okay coax County I'll have to find out
who they recommend
the subject we may also choose to do
next to nothing we just need to have a
statement and a report about it because
if you remember right the goess county
one expires
yeah but it doesn't expire until
November when the expiration get a
breakdown
but I thought they said that expired one
of them does you know
for some reason I'm thinking 2028 but
that's what that com someone said 20 25
well I'll find out if it may just be a
matter of we just say that it's due to
expire we recommend it we allow it right
simple enough but we may still want to
have somebody either send a statement so
that'll be if I'm not mistaken right
doesn't uh
um
so Bea does that Taylor Caswell so he
would have that's right yeah he would
come in both for co-ops and the economic
revitalization his agency is the one
that manages that okay we'd have cdfa
come in to talk about the cdfa tax
credit and it's
and the premium insurance of the
insurance department
I mean it would be nice if we try to
try to hit all five of these at the next
meeting because then at that meeting we
can then discuss it after you know we
hear the input and say okay can we put
together a report
and not meet again
or the way to meet again that would be
fine uh I I'm just thinking of my
schedule is so packed between now and
then I'm sure you guys Senators have a
uh
so if we can do it I'd rather I mean
would you rather I mean we could start a
little earlier too we started at 10 30
today because representative Ames had a
conflict
um if we started a little earlier I
don't know what's the earliest
nine everyone's okay with nine actually
let's try to figure out a date
um
and then you know we might be done by 12
and that way we got through them
okay
um
Monday October 16th look
what was the date I'm sorry Monday
Monday October 16th
yeah I don't know that's um
oh that's there's some sort of hfpi
conference New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute conferences all day and I know
many people are going to that well
there's just it's just us five right
yeah
what is it I don't know what is it
they've sent out a lot of notices yeah
yeah I mean you can't do the 17th I can
do the 18th
I have a dedicated funds committee
meeting
on the 18th yeah 19th I have Ways and
Means
I mean I'm available Friday the 20th I
guess
getting
at that point we're probably gonna have
to finish up in or at least have a
preliminary report
um does Friday I like to try to stay
away from Fridays but does Friday the
20th works for me it's okay if we go
back a week what's that instead of a
Friday when we look at like Tuesday the
10th left over uh Tuesday the 10th I'm
sadly I'm in La for a few days wow
because the the earliest I can do it
for that I mean I think next week is
probably too quick
actually I've got something
if I got something scheduled oh no
Thursday Thursday the 28th
you know now we're pushing again report
deadline November one
no no I'm back in September now oh
September 28th but I don't know if
that's too
quick that's only that's a week from
today we gotta schedule people
away from today I'm out you're out I'm
not here oh that's right you're you're
uh yeah I think part of the issue is
you're gone that week and into
October first week right deck your yeah
October I'm back uh October 4th and then
I'm gone from the fifth to the 11 to the
12th actually so yeah the week of the
16th is the earliest I can
um
and unfortunately Tuesday I have joint
committee to study charitable gaming
actually you're on that too which one
that's yeah that's Tuesday
um that's Tuesday the 17th that's why I
said I couldn't make it yeah Wednesday
the 18th I have dedicated funds 19th I
have a ways and means so what time is
your dedicated funds
um
10 o'clock
oh right so you're awesome
okay so Tuesday and Wednesday
yeah okay
that's okay so and then Thursday I've
got Ways and Means Friday the 20th what
did we say about this it's okay with me
but
um
yeah because actually the fifth one is
is dra the credit carry forward I don't
think that's going to take that long
um Insurance isn't going to take that
long
um
spanium will take that long they
shouldn't take that long so we should be
able to get through them all and
hopefully draw some conclusions and and
not have to meet again we say nine nine
o'clock
um October 20th
and if and if one of these entities
can't come and give us report then I'll
ask for a written report so we can at
right
yep move to adjourn
second second yep all in favor